en ouvrant ses portes en janvier dernier
dans le quartier saint michel
l'organisme progede ne pensais jamais
recevoir autant de demandes aide
alimentaire 30 familles ok bon arrive le
coc vide c'était une explosion
en ce moment on est rendu à 180 à 200
familles par semaine qu'on nourrit tous
les vendredis la file s'allonge dès
l'heure du midi
la crise sanitaire ne cesse d'attirer
des gens qui n'ont pas l'habitude des
banques alimentaires
j'aurais pu j'ai publié il ya neck
marche je commence seulement comme un
ouais parce que c'est un besoin
simplement pour moi puis a touché rives
il faut qu'on mange les familles puis il
faut qu'il y ait quelque chose pour tout
le monde fait que j'espère que ça va
durer longtemps
et le fait est que la vie a changé pour
tout le monde et qu'il y en a que pour
cette raison se sont trouvés dans une
situation plus précaire
c'est pas croisé passage en août dans un
imprévu à un probable des semblables
afin progede est approvisionnée par
moisson montréal qui a distribué 37% de
plus de denrées que l'an dernier
notre 1er avril et puis le 30 septembre
monde a donné 50 5 millions de dollars
de nourriture aux organismes de montréal
but du québec c'est 15 millions de
dollars de plus que qu'est ce qu'on
avait fait l'année passée c'est 37 % de
plus qu on était capable de livrer la
marchandise
après une profusion de dons au printemps
les banques alimentaires doivent faire
face à la suite des choses
maintenant ce qui nous inquiète le plus
c'est que les gens qui perdent leur
emploi aujourd'hui on sait qu'on est en
ralentissement économique
ils trouveront pas d'emploi ont taraudé
fois de 2 3 ans donc nous on pense pas
que ça aujourd'hui on pense à comment va
faire pour soutenir ces gens là pour les
deux trois prochaines années
la générosité sera telle mise sur pause
la grande guignolée des médias qui a
lieu depuis 20 ans décembre et toutes
les collectes du temps des fêtes devront
se faire autrement mais capable de
passer deux fois plus éclairant qu'on en
passe présentement pour pouvoir mettre
la main sur les kilos- évidemment mais
le boulot des règlements risque d'être
auprès des organismes communautaires ce
zoo ou temps qui changent la vie des
jeunes progede songe à offrir une
deuxième journée de distribution
hebdomadaire pour faire face à
l'augmentation du besoin ici anne louise
despatie radio-canada mourir